I feel like too many of these
celebrities just said I'll do whatever
is popular and now it's blowing up in
their faces because they ended up saying
wa wa wa hold on I can't support that
not to mention it's this really weird
circumstance where you do have massive
massive popular support for for
Palestine critical of Israel but you
have major corporations that aren't
having none of it a lot of these
celebrities are concerned they're going
to lose money they're going to lose jobs
they're going to get fired if they're
critical of Israel but at the same time
if you're supporting Israel you're
getting fired too so it's like double
cancel culture going on who's gotten
fired for supporting Tara Strong Tara
Strong she's a voice actress she got
fired without notification because she
was posting a bunch of stuff on on
Twitter like I stand with Israel people
were kidnapped and whatas is doing and
then they abruptly post saying we'll no
longer be working with her on the show
and she's like one of the most famous
voice
actresses excuse me okay in the world I
haven't heard of that my whole life I've
seen people getting cancelled and
smeared and fired for criticizing Israel